hello everyone good evening I like to
want to country should be let's - that's
not the basic thought Northern
California tonight we have a excellence
distinguished speaker but before we
introduce it hope you enjoy the
sandwiches and cookies we've learned to
make those ourselves I've watched well
but every day a vial for sale so I was a
social company or quest become an
internet sensation and inspiration for
his fund and highly effective
educational videos on YouTube every
month more than hundred thousand
students both Cal Gables across the
globe uses over 1300 free videos to
learn about arithmetics - chemistry -
vector calculus he founded the Kahn
Academy which was recently covered on
CNN CBS News NPR San Francisco Chronicle
and ABC nine month his mission is
nothing short of creating a free
world-class virtual school for anyone
the world you will speak about his
experience starting the Academy and
massively transformational changes in
learning and teaching and you think so
I've had pool in the next five to ten
years South Africa from MIT in 1988 with
computer science and math degrees and
receive his MBA from Harvard Business
School he left his day job as a hedge
fund analyst in 2009 to dedicate
full-time to his nonprofit academy and
we're delighted and honored we have this
distinguished speaker tonight in
American giant online educational space
a world-class educator and dynamic
communicator and a selfless
good
y'all hear me I'd prefer to just like be
closer to you Alden can you hear me in
the back okay okay cool so so just like
Ed's I'm Sal founder and faculty of the
Khan Academy this is and what you know
and I really want to make this you know
we're a bunch of you know I think it'll
be a fun conversation I don't want this
to be like you know we have the
PowerPoint for the whole hour so I
really want y'all to interrupt me a
raise you know raise your hand ask any
questions and we can take this wherever
we want to go because there's really a
couple of different conversations we can
have and and maybe we can have a ball so
for those of you all I'm give you all
have watched a Khan Academy video or
okay so that's pretty good car okay so
so just so you know what it is and and
actually maybe to get a sense of the
growth you know I said 100,000 and when
I when you first asked me to do this
100,000 now it's 200,000 unique students
a month and it's only been like two
months so it is the fastest growing open
course effort and it's now it actually
passed up I'm not like I'm a little
competitive the past of MIT recently in
terms of being the most used is getting
about 60 or 70 thousand video views a
day has about close to 16 million views
on YouTube so so it's you know I mean
and and and one of the things we can
talk about is maybe why and it might be
something about the content how it's how
it's delivered and whatnot we can we can
talk about all of that but this is this
is the site just so for those of you
have never seen it and we can also
debate my user interface skills for just
putting all 1400 links on one page that
felt those are the videos and if you on
a random video you don't want a review
of eigen vectors and eigen space is you
can click there and when you let it
but that's the kind of cavity and what I
want to do so that's
and it's
there's no well it's not that does it
sound is a difference in what you're
hearing right now hear my voice you
don't so this is this will give you a
flavor for the form factor that could be
a conversation we could have about why
this is an interesting form factor or
why I did it and all of that type of
thing
well what I'm gonna focus on because I
think most people are familiar with the
video library's it has this reach it's
you know it's got the popular it's
growing a 10 or 15% a month at this
point but I want to talk about kind of
the bigger vision you know edit and it
talked about this idea of starting a
virtual school for the world and
obviously you know videos are a start
the kind of the lecture part of a school
what a real school got to be more than
just more than just video you have to
play you have some interaction with
other people you have to have practice
you have to have assessment you know you
have to have data and all of these
things so that's what I want to talk
about and we can and I'm genuinely open
to ideas because this is kind of a work
in progress some of it is starting to be
built hopefully over the next few months
it'll be built at all in a much bigger
way some volunteers have come out of the
woodwork very recently the kind of
supercharge some of these efforts so
it's it's exciting times so let me get
the presentation up
so it a good number of y'all saw the
videos how many of y'all saw the web
application on the site okay so that's a
much lower penetration rate that so just
so y'all know a little bit of the
history and I'm happy to go into this as
much as you want but I started doing
this remotely tutoring cousin I was in
Boston my cousins were in New Orleans
and she was having trouble with units
and I said hey let's you know after
school after your school my work let's
get together virtually we'll use Yahoo
do it a lot you know it'll be a shared
notepad that we can each see what each
other's writing I got her a little Wacom
pen tablet I have one for myself and we
just do conference calls and that's how
I started and I started she started
doing really well I started tutoring her
brothers other cousins and then a couple
there couple of things happen and I
usually go straight to the videos
because that's what it's known for but
being kind of a computer science geek I
thought I didn't even think of doing the
videos at first I said hey you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna write soft and I'll
always i'll give them these little
lectures and then i'll say but you know
there's there's i would just point em to
random websites oh hey there's a cool
applet on that website over there why
don't you try it out and tell me
tomorrow whether you understood what you
know whether you're able to do those
exercises or use that website over there
and I just get got really frustrated
this piecemeal you know website here
website there so I'm gonna write a
couple of JavaScript little things
that'll generate problems for them you
know so it's not like just 10 problems
that it can ok make you know come up
with some random numbers and give them
as many problems as they need so I made
a bunch of these motion with the modules
look like something like that this is
what a model this is like a multiplying
investment multiplying decimals module
and we can go into as much depth on on
thesis as you want but I started making
these little JavaScript modules for them
and it was starting really where she was
at units and basic algebra and adding a
subtracting negative numbers and and
basic linear equations and and that's it
but you know I don't trust you know I I
say hey Nadia did you do the problems
how many did you do and she's like I did
on my Dennis I come here I was like I'm
gonna put a database behind this
I put a database behind it so I could
keep track of when she does the problem
how long it was it taking her how many
times was she doing how frequently you
should getting one right or one wrong
then you know I started making them up
so each on that first slide right there
each of these circles is a module and
literally the first module this was a
very organic process it's really just me
working with my cousins and I derating
say it would be nice to have the data
and then I started making you know like
modules here one-off and I would first
just point them to it and then after a
while I was like well you know there's
some kind of dependency here because you
know Nadia got that but she needs help
with that so let me make a little you
know to fill in that gap let me make
another module and then after a while I
got tired of having to assign the
modules so I said well it should
automatically assign the modules because
there's this one she gets ten in a row
and this she's ready for this this and
this and so I kind of created this
internal dependency in the little owl to
do this and I said well this is kind of
a neat graph this is what I was using
just to keep track of the modules I
should just expose this to the students
so they know what's going on so this is
the app and it started well before I
made the first video and but it's kind
of like the secret of the Khan Academy
so you're getting a tidbit but but I
think it's also the future on a lot of
levels so this right here this is
literally level one edition so it's like
it's literally 1+1 and if you go to the
website there there's literally a video
on on adding on 1+1 and at first you
know it's almost a joke that I made the
video on you know adding 1+1 but the
whole idea of I minded besides you know
being cute is is is to give people the
notion that look you no matter how basic
your skills you can go to the site and
you will find something that that that
fits your need and the idea that you can
when you see 1+1 on the same page as
vector calculus or on the same you're
like gee there's just like up this I
just have to step through that thing and
I can get to vector calculus there's not
some mysterious and the same dude who's
going to take me through
you know my kindergarten teachers
teaching me vector calculus so you can
roll and and once this was made that
it's hard to make you know this became
what a lot of people in education talk
about differentiated learning with you
know data and all of that but it kind of
made me pause and say well you know this
is working for my cousin's but but there
was actually one piece that was missing
and that was kind of the I still have to
do you know what when I first started it
I thought oh you know it randomly
generated these problems and you know
pick random numbers here and then when
you click him it would show you the
exact steps for that problem house like
oh that's all you need to learn how to
do a problem you just need the exact
steps for that exact promise will work
for my cousin's but it didn't I mean it
would help them if they kind of knew how
to multiply decimals already but it
didn't kind of get him over that hurdle
I still have to do that one-on-one
session with them remotely and and that
became hard to scale and literally
another buddy from MIT where you know
dinner is I wanted to make youtube
videos while you know the things that
you do with your cousin's why'd you just
record that on YouTube and I was
completely dismissive of the idea first
like oh that's so silly I have this
software generates problems dynamically
what's a YouTube video gonna tell ya
you're right you know you're probably
stupid idea I went on as well you know
maybe there's something to it literally
when I kept recording videos with my cut
you know I would do the tenth lecture on
negative numbers with a new cousin of
Psych Jesus
yeah maybe a YouTube video will make
sense so I made the first youtube video
on greatest common devisor and this and
that and then you know I I said this in
a bit and talked before the immediate
feedback I got from my cousin's was that
you are better on YouTube than you are
live and and and the point I think that
that that he was trying to communicate
is it had none of the pressure of a
traditional tutoring session you know
did you get this and you're staring at
the person maybe I
as well and they're giving you bad
information because they didn't get it
and you know they can't they feel bad
pausing or repeating me but they can all
you want with a YouTube video or they
can go to Wikipedia or they could you
know or they might be afraid of even
admitting that they don't know how to
you know borrow or regroup or whatever
you know that but that now they can
actually review it in kind of these
one-off video so that was it and then
other people started watching it as well
said hey there's something there and on
top of that I incorporated with this
because that was the whole point in the
first place to have you know if you've
never seen this concept before you at
least have this outlet these YouTube
videos that you could you could somehow
access but before I like kind of go into
the depth of this I want to yeah once
this was built then I kinda had this
like yeah this is this seems to be
working but let's like compare it to
what goes on right now in the school
system and if you think you know we're
all the whole conversation the whole
conversation about education right now
is all about the student-teacher ratios
how can we you know how can we make the
inner city poor schools look a lot like
the fancy rich schools you know give
people computers but no one is
questioning fundamentally questioning
the model and if you really think about
the model itself yeah I don't want to I
don't want to you know taint your
opinion before yeah but it's bizarre you
have this situation we go into if you go
to the classroom and you have this you
are all in a room together so and we'll
talk about you know what you could do if
you're all in a room together but
there's no interaction it's just like
this broadcast lecture especially what
you to the university level but even in
the classroom at you know in middle
school you know there might be a little
one question here there but it's
fundamentally it's a broadcast lecture
to the room the teacher is pretty much
guaranteed to lose half the students orb
or half the students you know at some
point they're going to switch the whole
time you do that then you go home the
student has to go home do their homework
they do it in a complete vacuum there
you know they have a textbook every
other problem might be there's a
solution in the back you don't know why
you got it right or wrong anything
complete back if you don't have anyone
to help you if you're lucky you might
get a tutor or your parent might be able
to help you then you go to class the
next day and there might be some type of
your homework or something but really
know
realistic no real feedback and the cycle
repeats itself to get another lecture
then you go back home you do homework in
a vacuum this whole time you don't know
where what you're doing and all of it
the teacher has no data nothing that
that occurs for a couple of days and
then BAM you have an assessment and then
is the assessment you know some students
get eighty even the students who you
know some students get 50% 80% 70% 90%
the good students get 95% next concept
no one you know even if you fail an exam
the class moves on you don't know half
of the subject half of the material in
that previous concept and the class is
going to move on and and you might say
that family students about it the a
students are alright but they still
didn't know five percent of the concept
you know and maybe it was a careless
mistake but maybe they didn't know what
happens when you take something to the
zero power maybe they didn't know
exactly we you know what a fractional
exponent was that one problem on the
exam with the fractional exponent and
that age did the one who's getting that
positive label I mean we all I mean
we're a bunch of that's gonna when they
go to calculus and they see that fret
what are they gonna do they're not gonna
get 95% of gonna get 90% cuz they're
gonna miss that and another concept and
then where they go on and that's not
even to mention about the 50 percent
right so you have this bizarre the first
time you get assessment is when it's
time to move to the next concept there's
in no way is it actionable so if you
really think about the process it's just
this huge filtering mechanism it's just
this process where we're just trying to
you know every step of the way we're
just knocking more and more people off
and you know the lucky people in this
room we were the people who happen to be
lucky enough that we got we were
assessed and filtered at the right place
at the right time and you know that led
to us people feeling really smart and
going on and doing on but we just it I
mean that that's the what I mean it
makes you really question that we're all
lucky that's the big way so what's
happening here what I think is happening
here is that whole cycle it's all
happening scientific it's happening
instantaneously with every interaction
right the instruction if you've never
seen multiplying decimals before in your
life you click watch video it pumps it
from you to
you can imagine you know there's one or
two videos right now but you're going to
have ten videos you're tracking whether
the person watch the video you can
eventually track what the paws are
repeated where they watch it I'll talk
more about that later on time you can
perfect the content so they get the
instruction there then they can do the
practice so you're getting the practice
and you get immediate feedback you know
did I get it right or wrong if you don't
know how to do it you get the exact
steps for that problem and then you're
also getting assessment because every
time you do a problem it's tracking
everything about that when you did it
how long it took you well you know how
many times did you click hint and then
the paradigm here and I literally did
this just on a whim I like what you know
how do I know if someone really knows
something I was like you know it's not
90 percent it's not 95 percent just keep
going till you're ten in a row 10 in a
row should be the paradigm because then
and that would kind of enforce a certain
level of discipline I mean people say oh
isn't that you know kind of maybe but
not like when you take the SAT you know
you can't make those little careless
mistakes you should enforce a certain
level of precision so I just dropped an
arrow it doesn't have to be whatever
depending on the concept but if you
think about what's what's what's
happening Liat forces if you don't allow
that ninety-five percent student to move
on while not knowing that five percent
and then only get lost in the next topic
so that's the that's the general idea
this right here is the this is just
another example of a module this is a
slope of a line and if you know nautical
use blue handed you know it draws things
for you but it's just another indication
of and all of this is live you can go
right now to Khan exercises appspot.com
and you can try out all of the stuff
that I encourage if you have friends or
family members there was even a guy at
the hedge fund I work with who's going
to take the GMAT and you know he was
like summa [ __ ] laude from from Yale and
he's like oh you know what should I use
for my sake you should use this like hey
but this is this starting get one poster
let's just do it so that's kind of the
the self-paced student kind of view of
the world we'll talk about how we can
because I still haven't given you the
whole virtual school right right now
we're talking about videos and then
we've kind of automated the
self-directed learning and and learning
at your own pace and getting assessed
but but they have to think about well
how can you incorporate that with the
human experience
you know you're coming into a room
together - you know essentially learn
how can you use this technology to
hyper-charged that type of thing
actually before I even talk about this
there's actually a very simple flipping
of the classroom that I think should
occur tomorrow you don't even need any
of this software because the videos
already exist and some teachers it
wasn't my idea of teacher in London said
that he is now and you think it's
actually a no-brainer I don't understand
like this doesn't happen
worldwide tomorrow he is now assigning
the lectures for for homework and he's
having the students do homework in the
classroom there's no other technology
necessary and think about what happens
there think about what happens here
right now we all gather at seven more
you know 7:00 in the morning and 10 to
50 you know ready to read you know and
we're all with our peers we're looking
on and we just went to sit passively and
just be and just get this broadcast
lecture and then we go off our own and
we do these these problem sets in a
vacuum if you flip the model and the
lecture as we said it's one size fits
all I might be lost or bored I might
have gaps from the last lecture that
didn't understand but I still have to
get this exact lecture you flip the
model you get on-demand video that hole
you know in when you're ready for it
when you're when you're when you're
awake when you get it's actually I got a
letter from us today from from a student
about they they actually have a good
calculus teacher but he's two rows in
front of this really cute girl is every
day he's just trying to figure out how
we can ask her out and he whisks like
two months of calculus and this was his
only out but but that I mean that's
enough but the I say that's the story of
another person I think but whether we go
home and we do these problems that's in
a complete vacuum we have no one to help
us but if you flip it you can wash
things at your own pace
fill in your gaps do whatever you need
and then when you're in the classroom
you have 30 or 40 or 400 of your peers
to help you and you have the professor
who can walk around and in real time see
how people are doing before you know two
weeks before the assessment two weeks
before everyone gets that label placed
on their head that they gotta be there
student there which is if you really
think about it kind of silly and I'm not
like this touchy you know there are
these people who are anti grades and and
what it's kind of like oh that's
touchy-feely you know we know I'm anti
grades because I think it's ridiculous
it's not about it's because if you don't
if you're a B student you should
everyone should be forced to be an A
student it's it's on that concept it's
silly you know you'll meet many many
people and I think this room is an
exception but you'll meet many many
people who went through algebra algebra
2 geometry pre calculus trigonometry
calculus and when they see an algebra
problem in their front of their face
they don't they don't see it it's just
they have no they'd never had mastery of
anything in-between and this whole
exercise of going from you know going
from one who put an accident being an
a-minus student the whole way is just
it's just an exercise in filtering it's
not an exercise and actually making
people have have tangible skills that
they could they can do something
productive with but that you know when I
just described flipping them up that's
that you have no technology but what if
you have the technology what you can do
is teach you and this was this is
there's a bunch of student names here
that you can't see I blanked them out
but this is a report that a teacher
could have and this is actually a real
report this isn't you know like a
Photoshop version this was done in a
summer camp where they used when I
started in the last couple slides as
their their their math curriculum where
every students was able to work at their
own base and the teacher walks in every
day each column here is one of those
modules that you saw that first line is
one of those concepts and each row here
is a student green means that the
student ready got tended a role in that
concept they they did it
their cool purple means that they're
working on it right now that they're you
know that's kind of their frontier of
learning at the moment but everything
seems to be going okay and then red red
means you know what that students don't
like fifty problems I mean so kind of
you can think of the heuristic that's
done 50 problems ninety-five percent of
students who've done 50 problems in that
module usually move on the student has
not so some type of intervention should
occur some type of human intervention so
a teacher could look at this I neither
they can eyeball they could say hey look
everyone's doing fine but these
kids need help in level 2 division let
me just let everyone else work at their
own base let me just take these two
students aside and do a very intimate
focused intervention on just those two
students are even better you can pair
these two students up with these
students up initially and see if that
gets them over the role and then and you
can actually capture the data before and
after that you know I'm not there yet
but if the software is is actually
scheduling the interactions you can
actually see what happens before those
and start to rate teachers and students
and all of that type of thing and slowly
work up slowly work up to the level of
the teachers a lot but I think is should
happen and I and I hope it is this kind
of catalyze it is we go back to the
one-room schoolhouse we go back to a
room full of people from kindergarteners
all the way to you know anybody and you
know senior citizens want to come back
and learn and and they're all working at
their own pace and if you have trouble
with a concept and you don't you if you
don't know this we'll know that you're
having trouble with the concept it will
pair you with somebody else and it'll
know about that interaction they'll know
how good of an instructor that person
was before before and after you'll raise
them you know whatever else and then you
can keep escalating up and up the ladder
until eventually you can get by the paid
teacher so you can actually have a
reality we and obviously there's a huge
aspect of actually teaching people for
retention I mean it this isn't just a
way to get economics and scale this
whole mechanism I'm a ninth grader and
I'm teaching this sixth grader negative
numbers that by itself is a hugely
powerful tool I mean I you know I'm
learning things better than I ever
learned before just doing these videos
you can imagine if you're and this whole
level of maturity I think actually if
you if you hang out with people older
and younger than yourself you actually
act more mature for a whole a whole set
of reasons but but then all of a sudden
you have a model where everyone is
learning the classroom is actually an
interactive experience it's no longer a
passive experience everyone is it is
operating exactly at the level that they
need to and it actually scales you can
actually make it economic you can
actually have if you know P everyone's
obsessed with student-teacher ratios but
student-teacher ratios assume a model
that that you know if there's one of me
and ten of you that we can have a
conversation if there's one of me and 20
of you we're gonna have less of a
conversation what I mean 100 of you
we're not going to have a conversation
and that's true to some degree but here
everyone works at their own pace even if
there's a hundred students and one paid
tutor because you have this interaction
I'm willing to bet that you're going to
have a better inter
action with that one paid teacher who
cannot be paid 100 grand a year instead
of you know what teachers get paid
you're gonna have a better interaction
in this world with 101/2 teacher-student
ratio they could probably get in and
even though you know the fanciest you
have private schools that there are
right this right here this is literally
like you know that the the school the
the summer program had asked medicine
out cure to myself this was literally me
just doing sequel queries in the data
you know every night when I got one from
the summer camp but you know it's not
like a rigorous study but to me it kind
of speaks to the power of every student
working at their own pace and and kind
of throws into question than the notion
of our traditional notions of assessment
which we I think sense are kind of are
shaded began with so what this chart is
doing this is this axis right here the
days of the summer camp so it was a
six-week program and this is just a
count of the modules completed and this
black line right here that's the class
mean the class average so if you say on
day seven in this class of thirty or so
students the average student had
completed 23 modules that's what that
tells us and then you know and so you
can't even see that they all started one
plus one was actually an interesting
idea cuz we started a another group not
at one plus one and some group some
subset of the students always got stuck
they just never moved on even though we
started in the fifth grade and they were
seventh graders some subset always got
stuck when we saw when we started
everyone at 1+1 no one got stuck which
tells you that there are some smart
people who have some gaps and it never
gets addressed otherwise so you could
have the best algebra teacher on the
planet you have an innately very
intelligent kid but if he or she just
his little foggy on multiplying decimals
there's no hope they're just going to
talk past each other this is going to be
a very frustrating experience when you
started everyone at 1+1 and you see it
here it's kind of a very steep curve
this is kind of the review this was the
kids just getting a tenon or tenon wrote
a memo and then it starts to level out
of it this was kind of you know you can
kind of see the learning happening but
the interesting thing or at least to me
the interest
this is the green lines of standard
deviation above and below that meet and
you can plot all the students here but
this dude in particular on day five if
you did like a pre-assessment for the
class if you did an assessment right
here he only completed 12 modules more
than one standard deviation below the
mean so if you were in a traditional if
you're tracking students you say oh
she's a remedial student she's gonna
hold a class back or we have to hold the
rest of the class back for her she
doesn't belong and he did all that and
you would put a big label on her
forehead you're never going to be an
engineer and all of these things are
going to be placed on which does and it
actually does happen it around six or
seventh grade that is when these labels
you know these careers get ruled out for
students but because she was able to
spend a little you know and I was
curious I think what happened to her and
I could go into the data and I could see
exactly what she was doing she was
spending more time than everyone else on
adding and subtracting negative numbers
and just to understand this chart right
here
each bar this is the first problem she
did red is wrong blue is right and the
height is how long it took her so I mean
it's this is just from the data of the
interactions and so you can see she got
a couple of questions wrong then she may
be guests one right then you have this
big long time check she watched the
video here I looked at the video log she
watched a video here then she got a
couple more i but then G she still got a
few wrong so once again in a traditional
classroom she would have she would have
been said oh you know at this point you
are an A student you got nine out of ten
right or you got you know 19 out of 20
right your new student but know it for
sure to keep going couple more right one
wrong then finally she got ten in a row
and you can actually see that she also
got faster on it so there's a whole
other element of speed which you know
doesn't matter on some stands like that
but once she got through that one she
was able to just kind of her mediate
herself and get really build a strong
foundation she just raised head this was
just in six weeks she went from being I
didn't a second to worst student in the
class if you want to measure that way to
the second or third message all the
students are charged in just six weeks
so it makes you question you know if you
did an assessment here and I show that
because she literally raised through
level three linear equations which is
like 2x plus 7 is equal to negative 3x
minus 4 it's like and she thought was
intuitive after doing maybe level 2 she
just rang if you saw that soon you say
oh she's gifted she's destined to G so
it makes you really question and you
know we were just a lucky kids they've
got assessed at the right time you've
got all the positive feedback and and
you know we were assessed at that point
and people get but there's there
probably a lot of people who might have
been able to eat our lunch eventually oh
god blue got blue got kicked off so this
you know I'm sure this is data from
YouTube and it is I think it you know
everything I've talked about before is
how do you make sure a student learns
properly and and how do you make sure
that their foundation is bills and how
to use that data to optimize the actual
physical interactions but I show this to
kind of show that you know there's
another dimension of perfecting the
actual content so this is data that
YouTube gives me they you know they call
this audience attention and what they do
is they measure the drop-off rate off of
a YouTube video relative to the average
YouTube video of that link so let's say
the average YouTube video at minute 3
has lost 40% of its audience that's just
a natural drop-off rate right if I'm if
I'd lost at minute 3f I've lost 40% of
my audience I will be I'll be hugging
the line right if I've only lost 20% of
my audience I'll be above average so
that's what they're measuring thing but
you can imagine and actually I've seen
some a few of my videos where this curve
does this it just drops off and I can go
examine it in the video and my set of
orthogonal ad and I never define
orthogonal and I can either rerecord the
video I could put a little bubble there
where you can get more information or
yeah or just you know you're getting
real data that allows you to actually
iterate and perfect on what you're
producing and you know you can imagine
two dimensions this is attention you
could also have efficacy if you if you
couple it with the actual exercise and
you keep iterating on it until you you
have kind of a gem of the video and you
can even have multiple people's videos
see what's better for different people I
mean this all exists in like Netflix
there's no reason why it shouldn't exist
in education
so this right here this kind of the big
picture you know I'm talking about like
a virtual school for the world this is
what I think it's going to be and you
know I'm open to any ideas or any kind
of you know who wants the parts of it
well you know you have your video
library that's kind of the low-hanging
fruit first line of instruction you can
pause it repeat it you know one thing I
spoke to a journal of higher education
recently and you know sometimes I'm very
diplomatic I do that I want to rock too
many boats so I thought it was it I was
like a quirky mood and hadn't eaten for
a long time I often don't you for a long
periods of time but but I just went off
I was like I challenge you I checked
this is a journal read by like
professors and educate I was like why
does a 300 person lecture even exist
anymore like in what way like just gonna
be one way that that is better than
on-demand to you like this is this and
I'm happy for any of y'all to put but
there's no I mean it's this broadcast
lecture to a room of people at a certain
amount of time this 90 minutes long
people have gaps and the professor sees
blank faces it's just as all all around
you know I think only Rosetta existed
because people associated with the
college experience people expect when I
paid 30 or 40 thousand dollars I should
get this that's the only in my mind why
it exists with online on-demand video
you can pause repeat it the producer can
create ken can get data on what's
working what's not you can get your best
professors to produce the best content
and keep iterating and making it better
and better people can still enjoy gap so
that's what the video mantra is all
about then you have the web applications
you saw one of them but there's actually
another one of theirs there's some
jurors back the room who started working
on it there's a whole suite of web
applications you can build for allowing
people to learn at their own pace what
we what you saw was for math we're
working on something you know I'll be
happy to talk about it feel I'm curious
you know for for kind of more I guess
when a fact-based knowledge you know
learning American history or geography
things like that you can even have web
applications you know for peer
assessment for creative writing all
sorts of things I mean when you actually
compose things for other people to
review it becomes a whole nother level
whole other game than when you're
writing something for a teacher to mark
up and you know and say you're a B+ and
then throw it away so there's a whole
suite of web applications you build and
then on top of that you use all of that
data that we facilitate peer-to-peer
interactions
and you know I kind of hinted that in
the classroom but there's no reason why
just has to be limited in the classroom
if I'm having trouble with quantum
mechanics and the best instructor for
quantum mechanics is in Mexico City and
we're both free at 4 p.m. Eastern time
no reason that we can't set up an
interaction with a pen tablet and by the
way I used to do with my cousin Nadia
and have it interaction even better
record that interaction so that other
people in the future can use it I rate
them based on how they were they can
even rate me how I was as a student and
then the system knows what I did before
and after that interaction so it
actually knows what there was whether it
was a statistically significant
intervention in some way so this is the
big picture and you can just keep
getting the data and hydrating and
hydrating in an Iranian to make it a
better solution so that's that's kind of
the master plan so any questions or yeah
I know you've got this initial focus K
through 12 okay so one thing you said
really struck me as an educator which is
you're coming about everyone should be
forced to be an A student right so if
you think about you know this is an orc
change exercise with a lot of unwilling
institutions try to get them to change
it seems to me that this idea just this
one idea would be very powerful to take
into professional certification same
nursing degrees right where you're not
going to be a nurse right until you
achieve this level of competency in the
exam let's take a profession where this
idea that everybody does have to be an A
student right in order to have a career
and get them to buy into this model and
maybe get the resources from that sort
of problem or that sort of field right
to test these ideas out and to show how
they work or define the implementation
or whatever you know I think I mean I
think it exists in professional
development because people say look if
you're a nurse and you don't know this
people are gonna die and so they do
enforce that you know doctors nurses and
police you know that exists and but it
isn't hey you know you we could do
studies but but I think I mean it's i
think it's almost intuitive that you
know if you go back to kind of the stat
you know someone has real mastery of
algebra it's going to be way more
powerful than someone who has you know v
- student level of understanding of alt
revert through differential equations
they're never going to be able to apply
any of it as opposed to I mean I've
worked at you know when I was at working
at a hedge fund there you know I there
was once a CFO who said you know as I go
what's your incremental gross margin so
go we don't divulge that I was like well
you just gave it to me I mean you told
me your your gross profit in two periods
and how many units you sold in two
period that's your every one of the
rooms
oh my god this is some kind of rocket
science that is Algebra one algebra one
and no one in the room there are MPAs
their PhDs in the room they're very
smart people but no one could recognize
and that is a failure and these are the
successful people in education so people
people need to I mean if we had real
mastery of algebra the world would be a
different place and all the counts and
all of that other stuff would be used to
be you know for fun but it's it's not so
I mean you know going I don't even think
it has to be tested it I mean if people
really understood algebra that's going
to be way better than people you know
halfway understanding algebra and then
moving on to do other things yeah a
question about the peer-to-peer
interaction so do you see that happening
now actually if you have 16 million
views on YouTube I imagine there's
comments moderation happening yeah so
there's no moderate so if you look at
y'all can go home and look at this some
of the art not debates or even some of
the commentary in the YouTube videos are
like what teachers would dream of having
either classroom like someone says hey
you know this was a great video but I
don't quite get what sounded at minute
234 there's a little link in YouTube you
can go right back to that little point
in the video and then other people say
it will come or not I say well you just
have to watch that other video and he
explains that in depth or here's another
page you could watch it or they'll
actually just explain it right there
this is just on a simple message board
so it definitely already exists and it's
literally just there's a lot of people
and I get at least you know five emails
a day asking for a better kind of
community to tap into this and I've just
been waiting to kind of do it right but
it's there and I mean people love to
help each other and they just don't have
a good way of doing it right now
I have children in the first grade and
what would you suggest that do with them
1st through 4th work 1st and 4th so you
know like and this is you know it's not
scientific I've tried out the app with
different aged kids like the oneplus one
it is one plus one but it doesn't have
like dancing bears well no I hope to
eventually have dancing I mean everyone
likes dancing you don't a kindergartner
but I found like kindergarten
I'd see some precocious second or third
graders get into it like they don't need
the dancing bears and the music and all
of that type of thing so you're fourth
grader I think could be could be you
know ready for this the videos I've seen
very young kids like them they like the
I don't know what they like about it
they like the the black background and
the colors and they respond to they
respond to the videos I've seen three or
four year-olds it holds their attention
on up their retaining anything so you
might want to start with the videos for
your younger student and and then but
the fourth grader I think is ready for
the app yeah I think so and you might
want to watch it with them and they kind
of you know as some people told me that
they watch a couple videos at night with
their kids kind of replaced the bin time
story so are your videos and your system
a little too big for one lap times a
child so the question is is your video
in your system a little too big for one
laptop per child and I guess there's a
couple of in terms of just what getting
any of that content into there because
right now I think they just yeah so yeah
so the question is is it too big for
kind of getting the content into One
Laptop Per child and I mean that this
easy answer is no I mean that you know
when I first saw one lap for one laptop
per tile this was before Khan Academy
was really well thought out so if you
what are they going to do on that one
laptop per child you know they're going
to use it and there's examples of people
using it for lights and things as
opposed you know for for a computer so I
know I think it can be used tomorrow for
on what dr. bajjali did they have enough
space and yeah so I you know I reset the
raw videos they're gonna be on iTunes U
soon so I just talked the Apple people
and I handle them the distant and all
the raw videos so then another nod and
it was like 40 gigs and and I think if
you took the the flash versions it's 10
megabytes like 14 gigs so I think I
don't know how big the hard drives are
of those but soon they're gonna be able
to store
oh well that should be something you
should look into yeah that's a big deal
no I would love to I've you know if they
call me up I'd say yeah no no I uh
ya know I'd love to I'd love to and you
know talk about you know one thing I'm
playing a couple of foundations and you
know what I'm doing one laptop per table
with you awesome if there's the
resources but you don't necessarily need
one hopper top laptop for child to get
like some refurbish $200 PC put it in
the village now all the sudden you can
have asynchronous learning which is what
these village kids need because they
have to take off for the harvest they
have a whole spectrum someone can't read
some of them you know have a pretty
reasonable proficiency and that that
that $200 that $200 refurbished PC
instead of being one per student you
have 20 students per day working on it
each half an hour a day doing this type
of thing and then as a foundation for
the first time in like the history of
philanthropic giving you actually have
real data on what's happening in real
time on to actual utilization of your
assets where students are how they're
how they're performing and then in terms
of the actual cost it's you know a $20
PC will last for years that's $50 a year
and you're educating 20 students that's
two dollars fifty per student per year
for an education which is competitive
with anywhere in the third world
it's cheaper than pencil and paper so I
think that's what should be the model
you know but they get a lot that's even
better
right so there's so that the module so a
video if it's like a wordplay you know
the five people were emailing me right
now like some album I think I didn't
really do some kids don't work for them
but uh those type of things was just a
can out of a problem some of the emails
that to me it's like oh you know I
haven't got that exact problem before
let me just do it
that's literally you know the ten
minutes of the video plus five minutes
topology it's a very small amount of
time the if you saw that that first
grade I started world history videos
those take a lot of okay so when I
started on the French Revolution I spent
like a week doing nothing but reading on
the French Revolution like I literally
just took time off and I like Steve
myself in the country because you know I
think we've all found this when we were
going to school is that when you're in
the midst of a fuss you really are an
expert for that short period of time
until the exam so I really I I for your
time you could talk to any academic
anywhere in the world and you know all
of the details are the nuance and
everything so you know about a week of
harsh studying it's fun study right it's
not for an exam is for me and I need to
make youtube videos so I'll do that and
now and then I'll start making the
videos and then I could probably produce
maybe two or three videos a day once
once I have had the big picture I
understand the major pieces and I have a
kind of a sense of you know if you watch
those videos it's literally I cut paste
a bunch of images and match for
Wikipedia and then I just explain them
I'm gonna have a big math person so I
need that
to do things like draw perfectly
straight lines and doing the race or
something you can buy off-the-shelf the
prize or did you design that only
yourself no alibi some people have
offered to pay for it but I didn't do it
so so so and I don't so all I use is a I
started off using Microsoft Paint as I
made the background black and and I use
this thing called screw screen video
recorder too which is like this
shareware a freeware $20.00 screen
capture software that's what I started
the first called me for 500 videos we're
done like that then someone just send me
a Camtasia license or like this is a
great you need to be better of screen
capture so I started using Camtasia and
then I need smooth draw too which is
which which is you know
pressure-sensitive so it actually looks
like I'm writing with a pen it's
supposed to find this on page but it's
all you know you could get setup for
$200 at home with exactly what I have
it's all you know family stuff this
probably better stuff out there like
what I'm using right now I can't draw a
straight line with Microsoft Paint I
could have alliances
I have gotten letters from from retirees
saying that they started doing it in
instead of Sudoku and the big you know
other than you know keeping them sharp
and you know remember it they're not
connecting with their grandkids
they're like becoming the grandkids
tutor this is a whole lot of level
connection that they never could have
before so there is something and there's
you know and not the retirees there's a
lot of homeschooling parents or like now
I can kind of you know I don't tap I
think there's a lot of home schoolers
who are doing great until about algebra
and then what do I do next but yeah
there's actually lot of millet there's a
lot of people were surprised a lot of
military people roughly my age we're
going back to college who there's no
ending my fear if you're like in your
mid-30s and you want to go back to
college and the first thing you're gonna
see you at college is college algebra is
gonna be any suspect that there's
nothing out there for you there's no
like I mean you're you're helpless and
this is the only thing that's out there
and they're like eternally thankful that
they can relearn arithmetic and algebra
and all these things you haven't seen 20
years so yeah it's surprising
yes no for the question and this
textbooks Oh a don't get me started
though I'm really get started question
was I'm a traitor
and you think the videos can replace it
as a textbook and and let's think about
what a textbook is there's two things in
a textbook there's you know something
that claim claims to be some form of
explanation right you know pages of text
don't you know so and then it's
exercises right and there's like fifty
problems and you know a couple of you
the answer
I guarantee you on-demand video where
there's Khan Academy or anybody is going
to be better than that
pros or whatever you want to call it
that's trying to explain the concept and
it's usually explained more for peer
review more for the other textbook
authors saying oh yes did it rigorously
that's excellent and the folks for the
eighth grader who exactly 99 I think the
people in this small subset of people
who could actually read a textbook and
that's what a lot of you probably get
where we got because we could actually
consume that information for those
people there so on-demand video was
better than that and from an exercise
point of view the textbook company
doesn't know who's doing what exercise
when who is watching what what's
actually being effective they're not
getting real-time data that stuff I
showed I mean you can argue what the
module should look like but something
like that is going to be infinitely
better especially if you can tweak it
and get data on what's working learner
people using for all we know the
textbook publishers you know half of the
problems are never touched by anybody
but they're in there and kids are
getting hernias carrying those problems
around no so yes the answer is I think I
think the textbooks argue to go on
what kind of problems yes oh so the
question is for old history what kind of
problems can you put out there so right
now like yeah so so far like what I
showed you that those modules that's
good for something that can be like
templatized
that you can you know math you can even
do some sort of like physics problems
like that like that the core problems
you could do some types of chemistry
maybe genetics but what about you know
what were the cause of the Civil War
oh yeah so there's two levels of things
I kissed you one is kind of the you know
what did you learn so more do you know
there's that level and then there's a
level of you know let's talk about what
you know the impacts of slavery donators
or something more new one but the core
stuff and that's what I'm working on
with those two gentlemen back there did
Jane just all at the back they they we
met like last week you know there but
what we're working on is a you know what
we're working on you know if we were
studying for like a factual base thing
we would get together in a big study
group and you know write flash cards for
each other and then quiz each other on
each other's questions and so what we're
working on is you know kind of a world
you don't get for American history put
the whole curriculum there and then if
you say you know I wanna write a
question on the end developer you click
at the bell on your right a question you
can embed a video image whatever you
want once you feel good about it you put
the correct choice incorrect choices
explanation once you feel good about it
you publish it if I'm the first person
to see your your your your question I'll
say hey warning this is an unintentional
question oh and all of that stuff but
you should try it out I do the question
I read on quality difficulty and
importance and then you start building
this librarian questions with metadata
around it and then you can imagine if
you're collecting data people when you
this question didn't know that question
so you can quantitatively say what's the
easier what's harder I think there's all
sorts of ways you can consume this
question you could imagine a teacher
you're getting all of this data right
you're you know exactly how long it
takes for a certain type of students who
complete a question whether they get it
right on you could have a imagine a
history teacher once you have this huge
data huge library questions like you
know what I would administer of an exam
to mine mr. Issa mr. Baumann to bring
them in the computer lab I want 50
questions at those and no and I don't
want more than a 95% chance that more
than two people are going to finish that
exam and we'll have all of the data
because it'll know for that level of
student I mean how long it will take
them it'll be able to do the statistical
model and then BAM I'll get em I'll be
consistently great and you'll get the
data going to them and they could have
their students elsewhere so so that
before like the decor and you can do
that for anything we're kind of working
who wants to math problems stuff that's
not quite the temporal time the more
nuanced stuff I you know that's so good
I'm open to ideas you know I think
there's there's there's things you know
a peer review of essays you know like or
you could argue you know you have argue
through essays and have people vote on
whose arguments that there's all sorts
of things you can do that's a whole
other but it hasn't been well know for
language I think you got a 15 month old
you know Skype exists like the best
foreign language just I'm gonna have him
check for half an hour a week with
somebody in Mexico City you know Dubai
you know honk I mean you know and half
an hour weekend up this chat the old
speaking ink it up that's foreign
language like this I mean I think
there's some very simple things with
found technology right now that that
could solve some of these problems and
they'll be a version as opposed to
oh very curious to hear your thoughts
about the Texas Board of Education and
so have you heard about the Texas Board
of Education testing we're trying to
rewrite the textbooks that serve make
you rethink about your mission with oh
yeah so that's interesting so I'm an
interesting so he that's what the Texas
Board of Education of the rewriting
American history and all that we are
from a personal level that's the power
of this thing like I can all of a sudden
get it so I do every now that I go on
Google Blog search and I see who's using
these kind of computers and all that but
actually a white supremacy group it
loves the Khan Academy you know because
like this is quality instruction our
kids aren't getting it this is the only
way that they're gonna be able to
compete with the Asians we're not
meeting you know teasing or they
wouldn't let me get into their house and
and teach their kid but because they
recognize that this is better than what
they're getting in the school I'm able
to get into those kids heads I think I
think that whole Texas thing I think
it's a non-issue I think what the
internet and all of that these people
can debate night and day over what
should be the textbook no one's gonna
care because they're gonna get
information from other sources I think
that the reality is mostly kids aren't
learning what I'm able to find different
people learn in different ways right and
so for example some people might learn
with examples and other people learn
what deductively this is can you
identify the ways that people
and adjust the instruction for to match
yeah so the question was can you adjust
to you know deductive learners versus
people who need an example yeah we could
I don't do it yet I don't think that
it's already done and all of that but no
it definitely could be done it that's
the other value of this you know there's
you know even in the some people today
are you teaching it this new way with
regrouping are you teaching the old way
with borrowing are you teaching the
abstract manipulative way are you
teaching the rover ok let's do both
let's do both and people can pick and
choose what they want to do both there's
not you know in a traditional classroom
you have to make these decisions because
you have a scarce amount of time it
scares the amount of resources you have
to say teach it this way or that way
but here just teach them teach it both
ways teach it the deductive way and then
do what plot of examples because that's
the way most people enjoy there's
nothing to stop you from from doing it
so the graph earlier where you show how
you get from Edition one all the way
food right and that's how the brain
works to build a type of foundation
right and you can extend that even
further by anything that's factual take
a history of geography by clicking the
Wikipedia graph of links for example
include imagine after you just learned
about the French Revolution and a lesson
without French geography you
we offered to take a look at that side
for instance yeah and learn about the
website you could learn about that sure
yeah a network of knowledge that you can
always do something no yeah no that'd be
all I mean you know that's yeah your
level sponsor no but I agree with that
sense you know especially what you have
a question library and you stink about
you know the best way to nap e'en right
now it's just a curriculum you can say
learn about you know the French
Revolution but this will kind of looking
organically what you're suggesting
and there's no reason why you know I
haven't built it instead of but it can
be built today and it's kind of silly
that it's not being built especially you
know considering how it leverages
something like thought about teaching
parents educators teachers on how to
teach how to communicate effectively to
your audience how to troubleshoot what
hang-ups yeah teaching to educators of
parents how to create so there's an
interesting story there to like this was
when Khan Academy was like you know I
was like happy if any would call me and
so there's like three years ago
miami-dade contacted me said can we use
your videos for teacher training I was
like yeah yeah sure that's awesome
that's like wow my daughter like real
educators and y'all want to use my
videos there's you know there is a
reality now where you should have well
yeah I think there would be value in
maybe look telling teachers like look
you don't have to be perfect just be
human and just being conversational and
don't talk down and don't don't try to
kind of use this as a kind of a power
exertion type of classroom management
time for people thing use it and I don't
blame teachers because the system forces
them to manage a classroom demand
respect they have a gap in their
knowledge you can't be honest you know I
can see like oh my god you know like I
can but like if you do that a classroom
then they're going to undermined and
there's all these other dynamics that
can occur that why student why a teacher
can't be
human so so but I think you know we're
in a world where we'll probably get a
subset of teachers who are scaling up
and then the rest of teachers be you
know leverage this to kind of become
that human one-on-one mentor and I think
that'll be kind of the value and then
you know it'll just be kind of example
if they say hey let's watch this
together and then did you get it and if
you don't look at I'll be your kind of
mentor to walk it through I'd be happy
to
yeah so the peer to peer that's that of
the most like you know on the drawing
board right now I haven't you know I've
kind of tried it out with my cousin's
that's a one-off basis like I feel like
it'll definitely work and you know the
data is being set up but you know not on
hopefully in the next few weeks we'll
we'll get some resources to just start
doing it because that's the most
technically intensive mm-hm
and you know we want to get to a point
where it not only we're doing
peer-to-peer and seamless and it's
capturing data but it's also recording
those interactions so you know you need
something so once you record this it's
you know it's something to do and I
agree with the whole teacher with the I
mean I want a world where you can if
your kids well if your parents want to
take you to Europe it's not going to
compete with your school you go on that
trip to Europe and you know maybe
there's another one room schoolhouse
part of the same network that you can go
to and meet the kids in Paris while
you're there or on the plane you can do
you know it shouldn't and it's all acing
on your parents or in terms of I I agree
completely and all that and the peer to
peer is the hardest to do and it's going
to be kind of the one that maybe happens
but I think a lot in the next five years
but I think it's the potential is large
what's the optimal length for the range
of different modules and how many times
oh yeah so that's it
so the question what's the optimal
length for the some of the videos
especially and how many times you have
to retype it so when I started off
youtube I mean if you go right now you
can blend this you to 10 minutes if you
know now they let me do longer videos
I'm a partner and all of that but when
you start attending this I was like I
mean I my first video was like 11
minutes and they didn't let me upload
that's not going to so I pay attention
to the clock and like I made my videos
around 9 or 10 minutes and that's kind
of the single biggest point of feedback
that that is the ideal amount of time to
kind of get one concept across while
being able to pay attention I've gotten
letters from people even I talked to
some people Google who have done some
user interface stuff and how long people
can pay attention and they said yeah we
stopped 10 minutes I think that might be
even what more did you do to figure out
that the living but that kind of forced
me to do that but one that's that's kind
of a granular truck that a lot of people
to pay attention it kind of turns into
one of these - Vince you and Dan Brown
type off novels where you know these
chapters like three pages and you're
like oh okay I've done it like you get
sensible you get a sense of completion
as opposed to a 90 minute lecture that
you only watch 40 days and you feel and
then it also makes it very granular you
can really just jump in and get exactly
what you need as opposed to sitting for
a 90-minute lecture and trying to find
so I found the 10 minutes is is you know
now I'm getting a little bit you know I
should I I've done a few minutes out of
pushing 20 minutes this is my fault I
really think everything can be done in
10 minutes and just and your other thing
is how many times do I do it you have to
take them retain
several times to get into reading
wondering in terms of interpreting I
know my quality yeah so how many times
do I have to - but when I started since
it was for my cousin's I literally would
record it and yeah there's actually one
one or two videos where i'm answering
telemarketer calls i didn't care why are
we recorded for it's for nadia one day
this is free what's he
and that's another take away people like
that informality right dad you know I
make mistakes like you know I would say
like one every 12 videos I make an
arithmetic like I forget a negative
number or I forget a little danger sign
or I say 16 minus 16 minus 8 is 5 I do
something bizarre you know and people
really like that alright I start a
problem and I go down the wrong path
first there's no way that's not right
I've got the positive feedback on those
things because you never see it you know
when you go to a class the teacher is
seat you know they have to scrimp
they've done that poem 20 times and they
just do it perfect like you know step
what you see someone kind of what
they're doing they do they follow their
intuition in one direction it was wrong
that's okay that's the art of
mathematics of solving a problem then
they go down a completely another so I
tried it now that it's getting like more
notoriety I feel like oh my god somebody
can watch this video let me like when
you do it but I find a more I think that
way I'm getting it hurts the quality of
the video I get just can't one or any of
the other page four
online services phoenix university baby
do any of you is a competitive threat
being free they should do capital Britt
or Phoenix use I've actually spoke to
the research group at Apollo Group which
is the parent company for University of
Phoenix I don't think you know I think
there's they're aware of it now I've
talked to Chris and review about
potentially because I would like to use
some of their materials and all of that
you know I think there's in any of these
groups even textbook publishers I've
talked to a few there's a group that's
like very like you know insecure about
everything and it's rad but there's
another view that's like look this is
out there and then this could even
empowered your instruction if I do all
the SAT problems out of your book but
hopefully you'll donate to me and I can
do them that's not going to prevent
people from taking your Princeton Review
course it's going to make your time in
your prisoner of course way more
productive because the kids will have
done the problems get all their
questions answered by you know the sound
guy and then they can have this
one-on-one interaction with the you know
the guy you're paying to teach so and
there are people as I [ __ ] a Princeton
Review and who definitely believe that
but then they have to fight the inertia
we have this billion-dollar franchise we
can mess it off so but yeah once they
really knew me as a competitor than I'll
start making security
oh yeah yeah oh so question is like how
do you build the curriculum how you
decide what to cover and you know I'm
not a fan of a textbook is like a
primary learning source for someone
who's I do look at textbooks you know
and that is a but I don't I don't know
strange section 12 1 next lecture
section 12 2 next lecture for me and
actually there's a textbook publisher
who wanted me to do videos for their
book and they said I want you to do
exactly this concept on this video and
after that concept I like there's no way
I can get myself it would be so boring
it would be just so mundane we'll just
kill like all my credibility if I were
to do a video on that so my thing is I
try to get the big picture like I've
told you what the French Revolution
spend sometimes all over it and then
once you have the big picture then try
to take it to the Nuggets that will
build you the big picture and and then
maybe do the textbook or or something
else just make sure your comprehensive
like the kids going to see everything
that they might face when they were they
taking us up in it you know I I use a
ton of Wikipedia you know I use
textbooks I use you know I use other
open courseware sometimes too but you
know a lot of stuff is hard to consume
if you really have to be motivated to
consume or even already have a
foundation to consume a lot of these
things
I kind of you my colleague is taking all
that and still get down to something
your data model mapping centered in they
are all on No
respiration oh yes yeah right now I'm
just tracking when they're doing the
problem how long is taking a what time
of day they're doing it did they get it
right or wrong they took the hint
all of that tons of stuff but there's
this whole like what was their blood
pressure while they were doing the
problem you know where did their eyes
move what is their you know their their
you know the cycles and their brain
doing on an EEG I think that'd be
awesome
like and I mean you could you could
actually do some final feedback stuff
and yeah but that's an old frontier that
I think is oh yeah something easy I
accept and their it I'm just if it can
be done try it out and see if it there
was research writing effective computing
in Media Lab and Rosalind Picard
that's what wonderful my pictures iris
Cisco yeah she was my adviser and then
did you sweats you know order mint and I
you know your eye yeah thing about this
one I kind of use the Khan Academy now
it's very content focused everything
I've talked about the videos in these
modules and all that but like where I
see it going is the content is really
just seeding in order to do all this
dating stuff to need the content but
what's the you have a critical mass of
concept in the data kind of takes over
and you can start doing some really
fascinating things with you know
experiments that you couldn't have done
before and like real-time learning and
they think that biofeedback and all this
other okay so here I think it'd be
awesome
the beginning of your toughest if news
visitors here defense types or past so
okay so there's okay so there's button
you know how do I know that it's fasting
I've every table for the second things
have a few like so so there's a couple
things and that's an interesting thing
about why so just on youtube which i
think is the primary consumption area
for most OpenCourseWare it has passed up
that my team you could you know you can
actually look at the cumulative upload
views on a daily basis and just measure
the Delta you'll okay you can see that
you know Khan Academy is getting about
60 or 70 thousand MIT thing about thirty
to forty thousand and you know I think
next up is perfectly sixteen thousand
that's just on that and then I don't
have access to my keys actually so you
can different so I definitely on the
Internet yeah so that's the other
interesting thing you know there's all
this open courseware you know people
spend millions of dollars putting
cameras but Khan Academy is really only
game in town of k-12 which is where all
computers and so you know it's not like
I'm like oh yeah it's there they're
kidding to us you know if we want to
review it we cooked you know we took
1806 already we just want to review
something we can consume that but that's
not for a ninth grader who wants to
learn how to invert a matrix or so so
for Kate's are 12 I think that's one
reason why Khan Academy without really
in has kind of picked up because it is
directly addressing its audience I think
on top of that you know the the open
courseware movement which I think has
been awesome but you know the first time
is Alyssa put videos in classrooms they
didn't rethink the form back didn't say
well yeah
is this really the best way to learn
online we're just
well we're gonna show you what goes on
in that mighty clock what I think is
awesome no it was no don't think I
probably let David alone it's going when
you go there why yes it's it's hard to
navigate we don't know what to watch
next
so it's not for someone who's never seen
it before there's no like direct path
and the other thing is you know it's
like you when I was making videos I do
like the entropy with you I spent this
whole time I mean I want to really
entertain entropy I want to watch a
mighty stuff and I was through the
thermodynamics lectures and I had to sit
through so much like non entropy talk to
finally get to entropy and then finally
there wasn't exactly what I want so it's
very hard to consume and and even when
you watch the video and I'm not I think
it was an awesome thing especially
because in 2000-2001 every other
university was doing something before
profit University of Phoenix type of
thing and MIT know it's gonna be pretty
so I mean I think it's awesome but
they're not if you watch the video I
probably watch I think more than any of
you all I want for OpenCourseWare videos
every now and then every now and then
the professor puts up the slide is like
this is a copyright issue he's cannot
see with this I'm like oh my god it's
not like or the camera is just not where
it should be or you can't see you know
so this it's a video I think it's
awesome for other universities to see
what MIT is doing and it takes a lot of
security on the part of that might be to
do that before do you think some
confidence
exactly exactly because I do you know
you have that because it says that
there's there's a value of being here
and it also is look this leaves us open
could before this everyone would think
all these secret things are happening at
MIT
we're special and we don't but now you
know exactly what's happening and it
kind of loses the I I've talked to
OpenCourseWare and I'm open to talking
to them as much as possible you know I I
asked them you know hey how about I
can't even come back eight to twelve
offering because this will help improve
kids get am interested I'm an alum you
know and we could get other you know
they work they're putting video cameras
in the classroom Trek you know like I
think that you know we could hopefully
that changes I think I would love to get
recruit on my two other professors to do
this form factor get other students get
all to do you know whatever y'all want
to do to the incompetency of teachers
you know there are very accommodating
fun you're incompetent X and
unfortunately some kids that's all they
get and I think there's a lot of that
and you know just look at the I the only
comments I delete from the side or when
like this profanely and even though
summer I don't get to so I mean these
are unedited comments and you'll see on
pretty much every video at least half
the comments are some kid who's angry
that they're paying X thousand dollars
of tuition to whatever and they spent a
whole semester trying to learn it and
they thought it was impossible learned
they spent ten minutes on something in
like that's all it was their aim they're
genuinely like they want to like kill
somebody so I think that's out there and
hey you know there's a professor in
Montreal wrote a blog post about this
she's just like you know even if you say
that this is above average instruction
it's better than you know and we could
debate is it better than 90% is it
better than 50%
but even if it's above average
instruction even if this instructions
been a 50% of instructors what's the
point of having this 50% I mean it's a
thought experiment that should happen
and even even if I'm not the 90 50
percent in structure someone is
and then you get that person or some
other 99 percentile instructor and if
you have that person then why are you
having the other nine hundred of hundred
but no there is you know a lot of - well
and it goes into a lot of teachers I
think our products at the same system
they're kind of this
right but the question is suppose
you know the question I think is you
know is it just gonna be me other other
potential people and you know you the
top notch thing I mean it's not clear
that mi t--'s instruct should do better
than you know I mean those guys are so
the kick but like in terms of the
research they're doing all that but the
instruction you know and I might be
ideal for an MIT I mean somebody that
might see lectures I think they're
confident because they say look how hard
this class is the question about other
instructors you know when I started this
I assumed that was going to be the case
I assumed that you know I had done like
30 videos this is fun and people are
watching it let me get my other buddies
from MIT they'll make some videos and
then I'll see if they're interested and
somewhere interesting but it was hard
for me to get people to do videos then
for me to just blue myself and after
some point I had like maybe you know a
hundred or 200 videos and I said well
this is algebra it's pretty much done I
said I'm just going to keep going but
but to answer your question oh I'm open
to it and if someone wants it
a couple people Labonte and I said make
50 videos if I think those 50 videos are
of the same stuff but if they don't get
associated with Khan Academy they're
gonna have value by themselves they're
gonna be on YouTube the world in that
system but if I think they're of the
same style and you're kind of coherent
with the spread I'll push traffic that
way especially there's a guy who just
contact me about music
you must have music theory I'm lucky I
don't know anything about music and I'm
the puppy won't until you teach me about
about music so I you know I have a so
I'm open to it but it's I don't think
it's enacted but like a job
unfortunately
and the other thing is a lot of very
good instructors freeze up a little bit
in this form factor because it's
something I mean you are putting
yourself out there if you are Nobel
Prize PhD in this it's a lot harder when
someone Kerr says you then you know like
ya miss a guy like you know you know but
like when you're like the authorities to
kind of put yourself out there that way
sometimes a little I don't this is for
you you're cracked programming team but
how far away are you from having forget
the videos at least the drilling module
for say high school algebra one on a D s
or an iPod Touch so how far as a mod
from from a having the complete drill
set all of itemized all the metrics
everything being able to load put junior
on the back of the minivan yeah and do
two problems every 15 minutes or every
five minutes and teach junior Algebra
one in the back of the minivan all year
not having to go to class oh yeah I pad
or you know but you know I think it's
literally I mean we're not we don't have
but one developer for you know I don't
know six months devoted on that would
probably be able to migrate with the
data fit I mean how much data would you
need for that I think it's just a matter
of syncing it and and that type of thing
would just be implementation but I think
it could easily be consumed and done on
a push an iPad or something like that
there's no reason why I should yes
yeah I'm surprised it took this long for
this is smoking you're like what is it
there's no so it's not for profit 501c3
and it was interesting because about a
year ago before I quit my job I was
allowed to quit my job it was a good job
but I wanted to do this and and somebody
sees it contacted you say hey we love
what you're doing and we think you're
doing an education Brian all of this how
do we do a hybrid model you can work if
you're going to get a salary you can do
this but what have some premium content
you know and I was I was very close to
doing that but then the more and what I
thought about it especially when I spoke
to them I knew that some point are our
desires were going to conflict and my
worst nightmare my worst nightmare is
that all of these videos I did all of
this gets acquired by mcgraw-hill one in
some library something they should
disappear somewhere that's why I mean
for me the real joy of this even if I'm
you know I'm forced to drive a used
Honda my entire life is that my
great-great grandkids might be able
learn calculus from these videos like
that to me is the most tremendously
exciting powerful thing so it is not for
profit it was being funded by my bank
account them so very recently I job last
week and in John Doerr wrote a hundred
thousand dollar check to give me a
salary so that's that's kind of so I'm
you know you don't feel too much you
know I think really large corporations
now that they know yeah this you know
I'm a baby show me a higher social
return on investment you know I you know
get a half a million dollar budget we'll
have three three four developers we can
educate millions of kids for all mine
it's not like it's not like this is a
charter school and as soon as the money
disappears the school disappears as long
as someone's paying $50 a month for the
web hosting is that exists forever it's
gonna now just being you know replicated
on it's depending on all sorts of hard
drive and we're going to put on bit core
and all that so we don't
for the web posting it's just you're
building a library that can continued in
to deliver social returns you do any
type of back beyond mobile population
it's like $500,000 for your investment
the social return is going to be like
hey especially translated into five
languages it's like two billion dollars
a year if you associate a video of you
with $1 I mean it's ridiculous so and I
think people are seeing that so
hopefully right you know is this
interesting in the way interesting or
interesting in then I'll repeat it yeah
so the question is is this you know is
this going to be do I envision this just
being like you know what Wikipedia which
is a tremendous impact what kind of a
supplemental nice to half of the world
or is this something that could
transform education and I think in the
short-term is the former but in the long
term it for me long term is ten years I
think it really is so you know a big
part of this I view this as the
operating system or the DNA for a
physical school and I am starting you
know I actually do a little summer camp
really for me to experiment with other
what do you do with the rest of the
school day because I've you do this for
two hours and then freeze time the rest
of time in the creative things actually
write computer programs compose music
you know instead of to actually build
the things so my goal is to kind of that
summer camps gonna get longer and longer
and actually the San Jose tech museum is
is going to give us some space we're
gonna start being a presence there and
so I physical experiments gonna get more
and more substantial and at some point
we're like we're a real school now
and this is the prototype and you know
and I don't want to do it if it's only
like a five percent better outcomes than
would be I want kids like yeah I just
wrote a I just painted that picture I
just build that robot and by the way I'm
12 and I'm learning calculus like I want
to see that and I think when you have
one example of that but I think of the
barrel industry but then I think as you
set the example and I think the rest of
the walls goes like wait you know our
$40,000 a year fancy private school is
not doing that and though that they're
charging $5,000 a student that's
supposed to I mean so then the next
question is how did you do that you know
this seems to apply to self selecting
students to subscribe the materials
right so the idea is this is right now
become to its self selecting for
students and even the summer camp I'm
doing and the other and that's true and
how do you apply it to a broader I'd so
I think there's two one like that the
summer camp that I showed the data with
that is the the selection criteria was
not you know kids in certain IQ or kids
who've done that was just kind of
non-problem kids so this was mainly
minority kids from East Palo Alto
Redwood City middle part who were not
you know they didn't have discipline
problems but I think that I can describe
like eighty percent of students that's
not you know that's probably ninety
percent of students and I think probably
the subset that having some problems a
lot of it is because they're not being
addressed in this way that they have
these gaps and no one can address it and
there's all sorts of social stigmas I'm
it's ridiculous that like concepts and
age are associated in this tightly
linked way that if you're 13 or you can
help with decimals you're stupid and I'm
gonna make fun of your type of you know
like it's missus and I think that leads
to a lot of social acting out and all of
that so actually one person I wanna give
this into prisons because a lot of time
yeah so I don't know the exact answer is
gonna be some experimentation but I
suspect that this is going to appeal to
a larger swath of his interactive
everything about it is there
never having to sit passively you're
learning the way people naturally want
to learn I think a lot of these you know
hyperactive kids or whatever they're
like natural learners they just don't
like being lectured to they like to be
interact you know interactive and talk
to their peers and whatnot so so we'll
see where that goes but it's an
interesting see you know yeah it's an
interesting question if there is
something that can really accelerate
ninety percent of the students but it
leaves behind ten percent is that a good
or a bad thing and that's a whole social
debate that in case there is a movie
made a value can the other summon con
play this oh so yeah the other cell
money so effortless you've never done a
web search for Salman Khan I encourage
you to do so when you go home there's an
Indian actor with my name I've watched
second grader in the neighborhood who is
home-schooled and I'm afraid he's really
missing out on the socialization fact
right so you know if we transition more
than this method of teaching
how will we not lose that right so the
question is a socialization factor and
it ought to be very clear you know this
is it's going to be son the internet
essentially and someone could be sitting
in an isolated room because I'm not
having any socialization but the goal
when I just got the one out of one room
schoolhouse is that it actually is
social like for the first time you
actually do get socialization and it's
cool you don't need you know most of us
there's all there's a thousand kids in
the school house but you don't get any
interaction especially in a meaty way
you know accepted recess at lunch but
now this is actually incredibly
encouraging socialization in the
classroom where you're tutoring each
other that's actually very good social
knowledge hey you know we want to you
know if you think about what what what
when do you want to give someone a big
like thumbs up you can see you know
right now the system said oh you're a
genius you got an 800 on your SAT your
that's where you get the thumbs up but
the real thumbs up is you're a good
teacher you have empathy you have
maturity when other other kids respect
you for you know your ability to
communicate
talk down to them and so you know I if
you think about what people will kind of
get points for I wanted to be that that
the data and the assessments show that
you're a great teacher to your peers and
you know if you're if you're an employer
or university those are the kid you want
it been not the kitten was just a just
racing ahead and just arrogant I think
it'll actually help socialization oh
yeah I don't know actually I just had a
I don't know if they call me I'll go
I'll be if you get popke I'm gonna bop
tech this is